encore aujourd'hui vous voyez des
dizaines de réfugiés afghans ont franchi
la frontière hongroise dans des
conditions inhumaines
les conflits se multiplient dans le
monde et un nombre de déplacés augmente
à une vitesse vertigineuse
à preuve ces nouveaux chiffres du haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés des
nations-unies nombre de déplacés et de
réfugiés en raison de ces conflits a
atteint un niveau record près de 60
millions en 2014 dont la moitié sont des
enfants
une hausse dramatique comparativement à
la situation il y a dix ans alors qu'on
comptait 37 million et demi de réfugiés
et la crise n'est pas en voie de se
résorber car l'an dernier à peine cent
vingt-sept mille réfugiés ont pu rentrer
chez eux
chiffre le plus faible en 31 ans